suarez making his eighth start overall
his last outing as we pointed out in the
open five innings seven strikeouts
yeah that's a line drive base hit right
center field another fastball
out over the plate you always want to
try to hit the heater
ground ball out towards second that
might be two that might have trouble
turning two because of the
speed of the ball and they don't and
that means uh an error to dede gregorius
his 15th of the year
high fly ball to lefts
kutch says he has it
and he reels it in for the final out
senzitella maybe the best
stretch of his career over the last
month i think just the way he has
attacked the strike zone has been a big
difference maker for him so two up two
down and bryce harper comes to the plate
i just can't imagine why would you give
harbor anything to hit
out to left field going back on it is
hillyard back to the wall he jumps it's
gone
an opposite field home run for bryce
harper
he's reached 30 home runs
and the phillies take a one-nothing lead
here in the first inning
four home runs in his last five games
swinging a miss he went after a
change-up first strikeout for ranger
suarez hilliard's really struggling 183
overall
breaks his bat into the hole
runs it down
the side is retired no runs one hit
[Applause]
pitch swing and a miss good breaking
ball by senzatella antonio gets his
first strikeout
phillies
went elsewhere but it's not the reyes
here as he swings and misses at a good
slider
swinging a miss
the change-ups float pretty good tonight
second strikeout one two three go the
rockies
this ball in the air to deep right this
got a chance
and it is off the wall that's a fair
ball
and story is on his way to third the
throw not gonna get him trevor story
with a triple leading off the fourth
inning
fly ball shallow center segura is going
back story was late to tag
and he's going to draw the throw and
you're not going to run on gene
sigoura's arm and he fired it in
swing and a foul tip he got him change
up again he has three strikeouts all
three have come with the change up
and now wilker will come up with two
outs and story has not moved i'd like to
see the youngster pick up the teammates
here first hit and first rbi
this ball lined to center field base hit
come on down trevor story first big
league hit first big league rbi
as you requested for colton welker
outside and good at bad for hilliard
because he saw a lot of borderline
pitches that probably should have gone
his way you got to get the little things
done
like this bunt and that's uh
exceptionally well done
fly ball short right field way up there
plenty of time for harper to get under
it
and the side is retired
outside ball four wow he worked out a
very close walk it's the second walk
issued by centatella 1-1 on suarez this
ball is
going to stay in the park to left field
oh good pitch on the inside corner he
finally was able to tickle the inner
half and one out here in the sixth
here's the 2-2 pitch swing and a miss he
got him there's a rare slider and it's
filthy
0-2 pitch he came back with a fastball
and elias was on it and lines it into
right-center field for a base hit for
the runner at first base suarez ready
and a straight three called on the
inside corner
beautiful bunk toward third charging
welder throws on the run not in time
[Applause]
ground ball through the vacant hole on
the right side herrera hits second he's
on his way to third and he's gonna get
there easily oh he fell off the bag he's
out at third
he got there easily and he fell off the
bag
one out here in the sixth inning
lighter out to right that's a seed it is
off the top of the wall segura's gonna
get to third harper puts the brakes on
rightfully so at first
is that spot we've been talking about
and that is for somebody other than
harper to come through and it's brad
miller with two men on ground ball out
towards second bobbles will get one and
that is it a run scores the phillies
take the lead rogers couldn't handle the
hop 4-6 on the put out it's 2-1 phils as
segora crosses the plate beautifully
pitched game by ranger suarez up to 96
pitches so they let the they let him go
they took the reins off
pitch from the left-hander is a fastball
hit towards right field harper going
towards the line and that's going to
bounce fair harper bear hands it off the
bounce and that will hold dazza to a
single
ground ball toward the middle saguaro
flips the second for one they've got a
hurry
maybe they didn't have to hurry as much
as they thought 463 double play 58th
game for kinley
an era of 4.91
now he's ready and the two-strike pitch
swing and a miss kept it up in the zone
good stop by rogers from his knees to
cronin in time to get marshawn another
good inning from tyler kindly at the
rocky's pen all right so we go to the
eighth inning and hector neris is in
63rd game he's tied for third in the
national league in games 2-2
swing and a miss
95 on the outer edge two outs
here in the eighth inning one two
swing and a miss 94 up in the zone
back-to-back strikeouts it was a
dominant eighth inning for hector
nearest these two the rockies one ian
kennedy is on to try to close it out for
the phillies
46th game overall
22 saves and 24 opportunities
swag in a miss
high fast balls have been a thing
tonight one out here in the ninth inning
[Applause]
popped up
shallow left
mccutchen comes sprinting in gregorius
is there kutch makes the call in the
catch two outs
and this ball is pulled to left so a
two-hit debut for welker and the rockies
have the tying run on
with two outs
ryan mcmahon pinch hit for thindaza
marchand setting up in the o2 breaking
ball hit in the air to right field oh
man oh man it is gone
it's a two-run home run and the rockies
have taken a 3-2 lead and this thursday
night crowd fly it for about three
seconds before they let their
displeasure
be known
it's the first breaking pitch that he's
thrown in this inning
now sam hilliard
wow that one's going to go even farther
it's a fairer foul it is a fair ball
home run and that is hit a ton
hilliard's 10th home run of the year
he's gone back to back with mcmahon
it's now four to two in favor of the
rockies
through the hole on the left side a base
hit for brad miller
[Applause]
live drive out to left field that's
going to be in for a base hit
miller's on his way to third
mccutcheon's on his way to second the
throw goes to second
not in time
the tying run is at second base
and there is still life left in the legs
of the fields
deedy is over two tonight a pair of
strikeouts and a walk bouncer out to the
right side it'll get a run home
but an out is recorded it moves
mccutcheon the tying run to third and it
brings real muto up
the 2-2 swing and a miss he got 98 up he
missed his spot but he got the save
and the rockies have taken game one in a
heartbreaker over the phils by a final
score of four to three
[Applause]